>> RENEE WAS DISHING OUT
OPINIONS ONCE AGAIN.
>> DO YOU HONESTLY THINK THAT
THERE'S EVER GONNA BE A
PLUS-SIZED MODEL
ON THE COVER OF "VOGUE"?
>> GET OUT OF MY FACE.
>> GO!
>> GO! LET'S GO!
>> SARAH'S CHALLENGE WIN
GAVE HER THE ADVANTAGE
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
>> THIS EXERCISE MAY HAVE SAVED
YOU IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> BUT DIANA AND WHITNEY
STRUGGLED.
>> THERE'S STILL
AN ELEMENT OF CONTROL THERE.
>> IN THE END,
DIANA'S LACK OF FOCUS
WAS HER UNDOING...
DIANA, WE DON'T FEEL
THAT FIRE AND THAT PASSION.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
EIGHT GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> DO YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪
>> DIANA, DARLING.
(laughs)
DIANA WAS MY BEST FRIEND IN THE
HOUSE.
WHEN SHE FIRST LEFT,
IT DID HIT ME REALLY HARD.
WE BOTH WERE PUSHING FOR EACH
OTHER TO MAKE IT A LOT FURTHER.
I LOVE YOU.
AND I KNOW THAT DIANA
WANTS ME TO GO, YOU KNOW,
BEAT THEM SKINNY BITCHES
AND SHOW ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
THAT I AM A THREAT
TO THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "WOULD A ROSE
BY ANY OTHER NAME
SMELL AS SWEET?"
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> WHOO! ROSES.
>> AAH!
>> COME ON!
>> (laughing)
>> GUYS, IT'S LATE.
>> SHUT UP!
>> PLEASE.
THESE GIRLS ARE DRIVING ME
ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
JAEL DOESN'T KNOW WHEN TO SHUT
UP.
SHE JUST TALKS AND TALKS.
IT GETS SO ANNOYING.
SARAH--THAT BITCH
DOES NOT DESERVE TO BE HERE.
LAST WEEK AT THE CHALLENGE,
SHE DIDN'T DO ANY OF THE WORK
THAT SHE WAS PRAISED FOR
FOR WINNING.
>> THE BLUE JUST COMPLEMENTS
MY HAIR COLOR AND EVERYTHING.
LAST WEEK,
BECAUSE I WON THE COMPETITION,
I GET TO SEE ALL OF MY FRAMES.
>> SEE HOW POSE-Y THAT IS?
>> YEAH.
>> LOOK IT--LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE BODY LANGUAGE.
>> SEEING THOSE IMAGES
HELPED ME SO MUCH.
ALL THAT EXPERIENCE
THAT I HAD BEFORE, WHATEVER,
IS GOING BEHIND ME.
I'M JUST GONNA WORK IT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK
WE'RE DOING TOMORROW?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
♪♪
>> WE WALK INTO THIS RESTAURANT,
AND THERE'S A BIG BOARD
WITH A NAME WRITTEN ON IT--
LESLEY HORNBY.
OKAY...
MM, I DON'T KNOW WHO THAT IS.
(Vivaldi's "The Four
Seasons"playing)
>> (laughing and cheering)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> OH, MY GOD, I'M STANDING
IN, LIKE, 10 FEET OF TWIGGY.
THIS IS CRAZY.
SHE'S ONE OF MY IDOLS.
>> WHEN I WAS ABOUT 15,
A FRIEND NICKNAMED ME "TWIGGY"
'CAUSE I HAD SUCH SKINNY LEGS.
THIS WONDERFUL PHOTOGRAPHER
CALLED BARRY LATEGAN
TOOK SOME TEST SHOTS.
IN THAT SESSION, MY FRIEND SAID,
"OH, TWIGGY..." (babbles)
AND BARRY SAID,
"IF YOU EVER BECOME A MODEL,
THAT'S A GREAT NAME."
SO LESLEY HORNBY BECAME...
TWIGGY!
SUDDENLY, THREE WEEKS LATER,
IT WAS THE DOUBLE PAGE
OF THE NEWSPAPER,
AND THE HEADLINE WAS,
"TWIGGY--THE FACE OF '66."
AND THAT'S WHEN MY LIFE CHANGED
FOREVER. (laughs)
HAVING A UNIQUE NAME
HAD SO MUCH TO DO WITH
WHAT GAVE ME MY KICK START.
TALKING ABOUT
CHANGING YOUR NAME,
I'M NOW GONNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO A NEW YOUNG MODEL
WHO HAS DONE JUST THAT.
>> I SEE MELROSE,
AND I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOD,
I KNOW HER FROM CYCLE 7.
>> HI!
>> (cheering)
>> HEY!
MY NAME IS MELISSA ROSE.
PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER "MELISSA"
'CAUSE THERE'S
A MILLION MELISSAS.
>> YOUR NAME IS MELISSA ROSE,
BUT YOU GO BY WHAT?
>> MELROSE.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> I DON'T NEED THAT "ISSA."
>> NO "ISSA"?
>> IT'S TOO MUCH.
TYRA, IMAN, GISELE--
ALL THESE NAMES
THAT PEOPLE REMEMBER.
>> WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO
IS TO COME UP
WITH YOUR NEW NAME.
FIND YOUR SUPER SELF!
>> AND YOU'RE GONNA
WRITE THEM ON THESE NAME TAGS.
>> WHEN I WAS GROWING UP,
ALL MY NICKNAMES WERE, LIKE,
MEAN NICKNAMES.
I MEAN, I USED TO BE CALLED
"CANOE FEET."
BUT I'M NOT GONNA BE LIKE,
"HI. I'M CANOE FEET," YOU KNOW?
>> OKAY, SO WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> I HAVE A NICE MIDDLE NAME.
I THINK "WHITNEY MICHELLE"
TOGETHER--I KIND OF LIKE THAT.
SO I DECIDED
TO STEAL YOUR IDEA, MELROSE,
AND GO WITH WHITELLE.
>> (laughs)
>> MY MIDDLE NAME
IS ACTUALLY "MOE,"
SO I DECIDED TO GO WITH MOE.
>> I'VE ALWAYS GONE BY "BRIT."
ONE "T," NOT TWO.
IT'S NOT "BRIT-T."
>> I KEPT MY NAME--JASLENE.
I DON'T SEE MYSELF
WITH NO OTHER NICKNAME.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS WHO I AM.
>> I REALLY, REALLY ENJOY
MY NAME,
SO I WOULD LIKE TO KEEP IT.
MY NAME'S ALREADY A SUPER NAME,
AND IT'S NOT CHANGING.
(bell dings)
>> I'VE BEEN CALLED "NATA"
WHEN I WAS LITTLE.
I LIKE IT.
>> YEAH.
>> GOOD.
>> IT WORKS.
>> MY MOM WAS WATCHING
THE DISCOVERY CHANNEL ONE NIGHT,
AND THERE WAS THIS
13, 14-YEAR-OLD GIRL--WHOLAHAY.
AND HER FAMILY
WAS MARRYING HER OFF
TO A 40-YEAR-OLD GUY.
I LIKE TO DATE OLDER MEN...
>> (laughs)
>> SO MY MOM DECIDED
TO NICKNAME ME "WHOLAHAY."
>> WHEN YOU SAY,
"HI, MY NAME'S WHOLAHAY,"
THAT'S GONNA BE
A CONVERSATION STARTER.
>> WHOLAHAY.
>> RIGHT.
>> I AM GOING WITH "NAYIEN."
IT'S GOT A LITTLE BIT
OF MY OLD NAME IN IT,
AND IT'S SPELLED
REALLY COOL, TOO.
>> YOU ARE NOW ALL GOING TO BE
INVITED
TO A VERY SMART AND SEXY PARTY.
>> (cheering)
>> YOU'LL BE MEETING
SOME VERY INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
WHO CAN HELP YOU
STEP FORWARD IN YOUR CAREER.
SO WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
KEY POINTS
THAT YOU SHOULD REMEMBER.
(bell dings)
>> POINT NUMBER ONE--
EXPRESS YOURSELF VERY CLEARLY.
BE ELOQUENT.
(bell dings)
>> TWO... DON'T
MONOPOLIZE
THE CONVERSATION.
(bell dings)
>> THREE--HUMOR.
TRY AND BE WITTY,
BUT NOT OVER-THE-TOP.
SO USE YOUR NEW NAMES.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
>> NICE MEETING ALL OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> BYE!
>> THANKS SO MUCH!
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO HAVE
SOME STIMULATING CONVERSATION.
>> OH.
HAVE YOU NOT HAD STIMULATING
CONVERSATIONS?
>> WHAT DOES IT SOUND LIKE
I'M SAYING?
I CANNOT WAIT TO HAVE SOME
STIMULATING CONVERSATION.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVEN'T
HAD A STIMULATING CONVERSATION,
ALTHOUGH YOU'RE SURROUNDED
BY THE SEVEN OF US.
WELL, IT'S 'CAUSE
MAYBE NOBODY WANNA TALK TO YOU.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
"IT'S GONNA BE A HOT NIGHT.
TIME TO TRY OUT YOUR NEW NAME
AND SHINE REAL BRIGHT.
BUT BEWARE OF
THE FUNKY COLD MEDINA.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> CAN I SEE
HOW THEY SPELLED THAT?
THE "FUNKY COLD MEDINA"--
I KNOW THAT SONG,
AND I'M THINKING
IT'S GONNA BE, LIKE,
A TRANSVESTITE PARTY.
♪♪
>> HOLY CRAP!
>> JASLENE. NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> I'M BRIT.
>> I'M WHOLAHAY. HOW ARE YOU?
MELROSE AND TWIGGY--
THEY TELL US THAT WE HAVE TO USE
OUR SUPER SELF NAME
AND GO OUT AND SEE HOW WELL
PEOPLE CAN NOTICE YOU
OUT OF A CROWD.
>> HI. I'M MOE.
I'M REALLY EXCITED
FOR THIS CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE DONE ALL THE TIME
FOR MY PHOTOGRAPHY
IS NETWORKING
AND MEETING PEOPLE.
>> I WISH YOU GUYS THE BEST.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> YOU'RE SO CUTE!
>> THANK YOU!
>> BYE!
>> I'M JUST COMPLETELY, LIKE,
IN AWE OF BEING IN THAT MUCH
OF A CELEBRITY-CLAD EVENT.
LIKE, IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
>> PARIS AND NIKKI WERE THERE...
JASON FROM "LAGUNA BEACH."
>> LOOK, IT'S JASON!
>> I THINK YOU'RE REAL LAME.
I'M JAEL.
>> (laughs)
>> AAH!
>> THIS IS 50.
>> I'M BRIT. (laughs)
(kisses)
>> HOW YOU DOING?
>> NAYIEN. (kisses)
>> WE MET 50 CENT,
WHICH WAS VERY COOL.
>> SHE'S A SUPERMODEL FOR REAL.
>> (laughing)
>> AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
I NOTICED THAT
THERE'S THIS WHITE ROOM
BEHIND THE POOL.
AND THEN I LOOK INSIDE,
AND I SEE BENNY MEDINA.
HE'S TYRA'S MANAGER.
>> THE "FUNKY COLD MEDINA"
ENDS UP BEING BENNY MEDINA,
A VERY INFLUENTIAL PERSON
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY,
PERIOD.
ALL OF US GIRLS ARE ASSUMING
THAT IT'S A CHALLENGE.
>> EXCUSE ME.
>> YES?
>> BENNY MEDINA, TYRA'S MANAGER,
WOULD LIKE TO MEET YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> COME WITH ME.
>> I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO.
MEETING SOMEONE LIKE
BENNY MEDINA
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO COULD POSSIBLY
MAKE OR BREAK YOUR CAREER.
>> MY NAME'S BENNY MEDINA.
>> BENNY.
>> I'M TYRA'S MANAGER.
>> YES.
>> THIS IS NANCY JOSEPHSON,
TYRA'S AGENT...
LARRY SANITSKY,
ONE OF LOS ANGELES' BEST
PRODUCERS...
BEVERLY JOHNSON--
>> BEVERLY JOHNSON.
>> OOH, YOU SAID IT.
>> YES, MA'AM! NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> GOOD TO MEET YOU.
>> NIKKI HASKELL,
ENTREPRENEUR...
MARKUS AND INDRANI,
TWO OF THE WORLD'S MOST FAMOUS
PHOTOGRAPHERS.
>> I'M KIND OF LIKE,
OKAY, THIS IS--THIS IS SOME--
SOME REAL STUFF.
>> WHAT'S YOUR SUPER SELF
TONIGHT PERSONA?
>> MY SUPER SELF
IS JUST BEING WHITELLE.
>> NO--WHATELLE?
>> WHITELLE.
>> YOU'RE LIVING IN A WORLD
OF, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
MADONNAS AND BEVERLY JOHNSONS
AND BEYONCES AND...
WHITELLE?
>> I HATE THE NAME PERSONALLY.
(laughs)
I CAME UP WITH IT
IN TWO MINUTES.
>> OH, WELL, THANKS FOR COMING
TO OUR PARTY.
IT'S NICE OF YOU TO SHOW UP.
>> (chuckles) WELL,
THIS IS ACTUALLY MY PARTY.
>> I KNOW. I FIGURED THAT.
>> AND THERE'S SMARTWATER
AROUND ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> YEAH.
>> I THOUGHT THAT 50 GOT SICK OF
JAEL.
>> I'M YOUR FRIEND, RIGHT?
I'M NOT INTIMIDATED BY ANYONE.
(laughs)
>> UH-OH.
>> TAKE HER WITH YOU.
>> AAH! HE'S DISMISSING YOU!
>> OH, AS MUCH AS I LOVE JAEL TO
DEATH,
WE WERE THERE AS A CHALLENGE.
WE WERE THERE TO NETWORK.
'CAUSE IN THE MODELING WORLD,
IT'S, LIKE, YOU GO
TO THOSE PARTIES, AND IF YOU
MAKE AN ASS OUT OF YOURSELF,
YOU MIGHT NOT GET A JOB
THE NEXT TIME.
>> OH, WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> I'M MOE.
>> YOU'RE MOE.
>> AS A PHOTOGRAPHER, I ACTUALLY
GO BY SARAH VAUGHN.
>> SARAH VAUGHN IS HOT!
>> ISN'T THAT HOT?
>> YES!
>> SO I--I'M THINKING, I'M LIKE,
WELL, "MOE" IS KIND OF WEIRD.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
SARAH VAUGHN.
>> I'M BRIT.
>> YOUR NAME'S BRITTANY?
>> YES, JUST BRIT.
>> TELL US ABOUT THE HAIR.
>> THE HAIR I SORT OF
PINNED UP UNDERNEATH.
I'M STILL GETTING ADJUSTED...
>> RIGHT.
>> TO THE WEAVE THAT I GOT.
(gong bongs)
>> I DOUBT I IMPRESSED BENNY
'CAUSE MY HAIR LOOKED A DAMN
MESS.
>> (laughs)
>> TELLING THE GIRLS YESTERDAY,
I WAS SINGING ONE OF YOUR SONGS.
"YEAH, THAT'S HIM!"
>> THAT AIN'T NOBODY.
AND JAEL WAS JUST--WHATEVER.
>> JAEL, STOP!
SHE'S SO ANNOYING AT TIMES.
JAEL WAS JUST UP THERE
JUST CLOWNING AROUND.
WE WERE THERE
TO ACTUALLY DO BUSINESS.
>> TELL ME ABOUT
YOUR SUPER SELF.
>> MY SUPER SELF NAME
IS WHOLAHAY.
(tape rewinds)
>> THEY WERE JUST LIKE...
(gasps)
YEAH, IT--IT MAY NOT
SOUND TOO GOOD,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME
IT CAUGHT YOUR ATTENTION.
>> WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
I'VE LEARNED IS HOW TO DRESS
AND TO ACTUALLY
LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
>> WHAT IS
THE MOST DIFFICULT THING
ABOUT WORKING TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
>> THE MOST DIFFICULT THING--
BEING AWAY FROM MY DAUGHTER.
>> AW.
>> IS SHE GETTING ALONG?
>> I'VE ACTUALLY TRAINED MYSELF
TO NOT THINK ABOUT
BEING AWAY FROM MY BABY,
AND I TEARED UP SO BAD BECAUSE
I DID NOT KNOW THOSE EMOTIONS
WAS GONNA HIT ME LIKE THAT.
>> HERE. HERE.
>> I'M A MODEL. (sniffles)
WIPE IT OFF. SHAKE IT OFF.
>> HERE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU--DON'T MESS THAT UP.
THAT'S HERMèS.
(laughter)
>> I WAS OKAY.
I THOUGHT I DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
IT WAS NICE MEETING YOU GUYS
AS WELL. (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT. SEE YOU LATER.
>> OH, NO.
>> GET AWAY FROM ME!
>> YOU'RE ASKING FOR TROUBLE!
>> I'M-A GIVE YOU A SIGNAL.
YOU GONNA SEE A SMOKE SIGNAL...
WHEN I WANT YOU TO COME BACK,
A'IGHT?
>> ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
>> HE'S A CELEBRITY,
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T BE
ALL OVER HIM. YOU GOTTA HAVE
THIS LINE OF RESPECT.
>> JAEL HAS A REAL
IN-YOUR-FACE PERSONALITY,
AND I ALWAYS SAY--
I'VE SAID IT TIME AFTER TIME
AFTER TIME--YOU CAN HATE IT
OR YOU CAN LOVE IT.
>> YOU AIN'T EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE
OVER HERE RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, I KNOW,
BUT YOUR EYES WERE CALLING.
>> I ASKED YOU TO LEAVE.
I ASKED YOU TO LEAVE.
>> HIM MAD.
>> (gasps) AAH!
(laughs)
>> SO WE'RE AT THIS SMARTWATER
SMART AND SEXY PARTY,
JUST MINGLING, NETWORKING.
WE GET TO MEET PARIS AND NICOLE
AND 50 CENT TO BEVERLY JOHNSON
TO BENNY MEDINA.
>> I ASKED YOU TO LEAVE.
>> JAEL IS DEFINITELY ANNOYING
50 CENT.
>> HIM MAD.
>> (gasps) AAH!
(laughs)
>> AAH!
>> DID HE JUST THROW HER
IN THE... POOL?!
JAEL DESERVED IT
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
LEAVE THAT MAN ALONE.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
GOOD-BYE.
>> OH, GOD.
>> COME ON! AAH!
>> AAH!
>> AND NATASHA
WAS RIGHT BEHIND HER.
WHY THE HELL DO YOU WANNA
JUMP IN A SWIMMING POOL
WHEN WE'RE THERE FOR BUSINESS?
WHAT--WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?!
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> (laughs)
OF COURSE I DON'T MIND
BEING THROWN IN THE POOL,
BUT IT'S NOT...
I THINK THAT 50's
A ALL-RIGHT KIND OF DUDE.
HE LOVES MUSIC,
AND THAT'S ALL
THAT REALLY MATTERS TO ME
IN A HUMAN BEING, SO...
♪♪
>> I THINK THAT ANY CLIENT'S
GONNA LOOK AT THAT AND GO,
COULD THEY HANDLE A JOB?
BECAUSE THEY REALLY
CAN'T EVEN HANDLE
JUST BEING NORMAL AT A PARTY.
>> EXCUSE ME.
BENNY MEDINA, TYRA'S MANAGER,
WOULD LIKE TO MEET YOU.
>> OH, GREAT. OKAY.
OUR LITTLE BUTTS, SOAKING WET,
GET PUSHED INTO THE ROOM
WITH BENNY MEDINA.
HEY!
>> WHAT?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> (laughing)
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> I'M JAEL.
>> AND YOU ARE?
>> NATA.
>> UH, BESIDES BEING A MESS.
>> I'M NOT IN FEAR AT ALL
OF SPEAKING WITH, UH,
SUCCESSFUL HUMAN BEINGS
BECAUSE I, MYSELF, WILL BE
SITTING IN THEIR CHAIRS ONE DAY.
>> I DO NOT GET
THE GETTING WET THING.
FIRST, LIKE,
YOU KNOW YOU'RE AT A PARTY.
>> YEAH, I AGREE.
>> IT'S GOING ON ALL NIGHT.
YOU THINK YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO IMPRESS PEOPLE.
YOU DO NOT MESS WITH 50 CENT,
FIRST OF ALL,
AND GET UP IN HIS FACE...
>> RIGHT.
>> AND YOU DO NOT
GET THROWN INTO A POOL.
>> TRUE.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU GUYS.
>> I FEEL THAT I IMPRESSED THEM
TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITIES,
BEING SOAKING WET.
>> TEACH ME SOMETHING SPANISH.
HOW YOU SAY "SMART WATER"?
>> INTELIGENTE.
>> JUST GET THE...
(guttural voice) GENTE.
>>(guttural voice) INTELIGENTE.
>> (laughs)
>> THERE YOU GO! THERE YOU GO!
>> HI! HOW ARE YOU?
>> ¿CóMO ESTAN?
>> WHAT DO YOU WANNA DO
WITH THIS WHOLE THING,
THIS "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
OPPORTUNITY?
>> I'M VERY DETERMINED
AND FOCUSED TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> NOW YOU CAME UP
WITH A NAME FOR YOURSELF.
WHAT WAS IT?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
I STUCK WITH MY NAME.
MY NAME IS JASLENE.
>> IT'S A GREAT NAME.
SEE YOU OUT THERE, ALL RIGHT?
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> MEETING BENNY MEDINA,
IT WAS LIKE A... ♪ AHH ♪
EXPERIENCE.
>> BENNY MEDINA.
>> NAYIEN.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE A NAME.
>> MY NAME?
>> NO, WHAT IS THE NAME?
>> NAYIEN.
>> NO.
WHAT IS THE SUPER SELF NAME?
>> NAYIEN.
>> THAT--I-I INTRODUCED MYSELF
AS THAT--UM, NAYIEN.
MY REAL NAME IS RENEE.
>> IT DIDN'T CONNECT
WITH ME BEFORE. GOT IT.
>> AFTER SAYING IT
A COUPLE TIMES, I REALIZED
IT SOUNDS LIKE "NAME."
(laughs) I KNOW
IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD, BUT...
(gong bongs)
(horn blares)
>> (laughs) WHAT A BAD NAME.
>> PARIS?
>> ARE YOU GUYS MODELS?
>> NICE TO MEET YOU. I'M RENEE.
>> YES.
>> DO YOU LOVE IT?
>> I DO.
>> GOOD.
>> I LOVE YOU GUYS, REALLY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU KNOW,I THINK WE LIVE BY
YOU.
>> WHAT--LIKE, WHO--
>> ALL OF THEM. THE BIGGEST ONE
HAS TO BE... PROBABLY JAEL.
>> OH.
>> SHE'S GOT THE SHORT HAIR.
SHE'S IN ALL BLACK. YOU SEE HER?
>> OH, OH. OH, OH, OH,
YEAH.YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE ONE I DON'T
LIKE.
>> YEAH, PARIS, WE THINK YOU'RE
REAL HOT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> 'CAUSE WE BEEN TALKING.
>> THAT'S HOT.
>> THAT'S HOT. (laughs)
>> MEETING NICOLE AND PARIS
WAS ONE OF THE BEST MOMENTS
OF THE PARTY.
>> SHE WHAT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
AND YOU CAME TO TELL ME THAT YOU
LOVE ME SO MUCH, AND YOU THINK
SHE'S A REAL... RIGHT?
>> I-I DIDN'T--I DON'T KNOW HER.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU SAID--
>> YOU SAID WHAT MODEL?
>> OH, SHE SAID--
OH, I KNOW WHAT SHE LOOKS LIKE.
SHE HAS BLONDE HAIR,
AND SHE'S A MODEL.
>> YEAH, THAT'S RENEE.
>> RENEE.
>> I THINK THAT RENEE MAY BE
A LITTLE BIT JEALOUS OF ME.
♪♪
>> YEAH!
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "FINDING YOUR ROOMMATES
TO BE TWO-FACED?
WELL, YOU'RE GONNA BE
FOUR-FACED.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> "FOUR-FACED"?
>> OOH!
>> WELL, I DO FIND
ONE OF MY ROOMMATES
TO BE TWO-FACED,
AND SHE'S NOT ALLOWED
TO PULL THAT.
NICOLE RICHIE CAME UP TO ME
>> I DID NOT SAY THAT.
>> AND NICOLE RICHIE SAID,
"BUT YOU'RE MY FAVORITE."
>> NICOLE RICHIE ASKED ME
WHO WAS THE CRAZY ONE
IN THE HOUSE, AND I SAID,
"JAEL IS THE CRAZY ONE
IN THE HOUSE."
>> M'KAY.
>> SO YOU CAN
GET OUT OF MY FACE, BITCH.
>> (laughs)
>> I'M NOT IN YOUR FACE, BITCH.
>> EXACTLY. DON'T BE JEALOUS.
>> (scoffs) YOU WISH.
>> MMM.
>> YOU'RE REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S SUCH A... WASTE
WITH NO BRAIN.
>> JAEL ALWAYS PREVAILS
IN ANY SITUATION.
SHE CAN CUSS YOU OUT
UP AND DOWN...
(laughs) YOU KNOW?
UP THE STREET.
>> OH, GET THE HELL AWAY
FROM ME.
>> I'M NOT EVEN NEAR YOU.
>> THE--WELL,
THEN DON'T WALK PAST ME.
THERE'S A BIG OLD SPACE OVER
THERE.
>> JAEL, I'M NOT GONNA WALK
AROUND ON EGGSHELLS.
>> WALK YOUR ASS AROUND.
>> JAEL, I AM NOT A MEAN PERSON.
>> WELL, YOU'VE BEEN
DISRESPECTFUL TO EVERY SINGLE
GIRL IN THIS HOUSE.
AND TWO-FACED!
>> AND--AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DISRESPECTFUL TO ME.
>> WITH GOOD REASON,
AND I UNDERSTAND
AND I BACK THEM ALL.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
Y'ALL DON'T LIKE ME EITHER?
"NOBODY IN THE HOUSE LIKES YOU.
YOU'RE THE OUTCAST,
AND BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,"
AND I'M JUST LIKE...
>> 'CAUSE I PUT OTHERS
BEFORE MYSELF,
AND YOU NEVER WILL.
I STOOD UP FOR MYSELF
AND ALL THE REST OF THE GIRLS
IN THE HOUSE,
'CAUSE WE REALLY DISLIKE HER.
(hair dryer whirring)
>> IF RENEE WANTS
TO ACT LIKE A BITCH,
THAT'S FINE WITH ME.
BUT SHE CAN'T EXPECT EVERYBODY
TO BE ALL FRIENDLY WITH HER.
♪♪
>> YOU GUYS EXCITED
FOR A NEW PHOTO SHOOT TODAY?
>> YEAH!
>> WE'RE GONNA DO
A SHOOT FROM TYRA'S BEAUTY BOOK.
AND IT'S A PAGE THAT HAS
ALL THESE DIFFERENT PICTURES
OF TYRA, AND IT SHOWS
ALL THE DIFFERENT SIDES OF TYRA.
SO WE'RE GONNA DO
FOUR DIFFERENT SIDES
OF YOUR PERSONALITY.
WHEN YOU GO UPSTAIRS
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE DIRECTING
YOUR VERY OWN HAIR
AND YOUR OWN MAKEUP.
>> I GET TO DECIDE
WHAT MY MAKEUP AND HAIR
IS GONNA LOOK LIKE.
YOU GUYS SHOULD BE AFRAID.
YOU'VE GIVEN JAEL THE FREEDOM.
>> YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER'S NAME
IS KAREEM BLACK,
AND HE'S AMAZING.
SO LET'S MEET KAREEM.
(applause)
>> WHAT'S UP, LADIES?
>> HI!
>> HOW YOU DOING?
>> BUT NOW
FOR YOUR CHALLENGE WIN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS MONITOR
RIGHT HERE.
THERE IS A MESSAGE
FROM MR. BENNY MEDINA HIMSELF.
>> LADIES, IT WAS A PLEASURE
MEETING YOU AT THE PARTY LAST
NIGHT.
BUT ONE OF YOU IMPRESSED ME
MORE THAN ALL THE REST.
AFTER TODAY'S PHOTO SHOOT,
I'M GONNA SEND YOU OUT
ON A REAL JOB--
A NATIONAL CAMPAIGN FOR KEDS
THAT'LL RUN
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE.
CONGRATULATIONS...
WHOLAHAY.
(laughter and cheers)
>> WHOLAHAY!
AND I'M LIKE,
TEARS START COMING OUT MY EYES
'CAUSE I WAS SO FREAKIN' HAPPY!
I WON A CHALLENGE,
AND I WON A GREAT ONE.
>> WELL, GUESS WHAT?
YOU GET TO PICK TWO FRIENDS.
>> AAH!
>> (screaming)
>> JASLENE, WHITNEY AND MYSELF--
WE COULD ACTUALLY HAVE FUN.
>> NOW YOU GUYS ALL--
I'LL GIVE YOU 15 MINUTES.
SO WRITE DOWN
THE FOUR DIFFERENT SIDES
OF YOUR PERSONALITY
THAT YOU ARE GONNA PORTRAY
IN THIS SHOOT TODAY.
>> THE LOOKS I COME UP WITH
ARE NOT NECESSARILY
EASY FOR ME TO PORTRAY.
BUT EASY IS BORING.
♪♪
>> THE EYES LIKE...
AND I'M THE DOMINATOR.
OH, YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH, YOU'RE BLACK.
>> OH, I'M GONNA
ROCK THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT
ONE BIT.
>> SO, LIKE, FLOWY.
I WANT THIS SO BADLY
THAT I FREAKED MYSELF OUT.
>> LIKE, SMOKY?
>> LIKE--YEAH, LIKE SMOKY BLACK.
>> SENSITIVE SIDE
OR EMOTIONAL SIDE.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND YOU GOT THE EVIL SIDE.
>> (laughs) FRIENDLY SIDE,
AND THE 'HOOD SIDE?
>> LAST TIME, JAY WAS TRYING
TO GET ME TO PLAY A BAD GIRL...
>> ARE YOU JUST
THINKING OF POSING
AND TRYING TO LOOK HARD?
>> AND I COULDN'T REALLY PORTRAY
WHAT HE WANTED, SO I WAS LIKE,
OKAY, WELL, I'M-A TRY
TO GIVE IT TO HIM THIS TIME.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> NOW YOUR EVIL SIDE.
BE "AAH!"
LIKE, I WANT TO SEE ANGER.
>> (laughs)
>> DIONNE IS AFRAID
TO GO TO THE EXTREME,
AND MODELING
IS ALL ABOUT EXTREMES.
>> AAH!
(camera shutter snapping)
>> OH, THAT LOOKS CUTE.
YOU HAVE ONE NOTE WHEN YOU
GO INTO THIS LAST ONE--
SO THE 'HOOD SIDE, HIT IT.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> LAST FRAME.
>> WHATEVER.
♪♪
>> YOU KNOW HOW
IN "THE JUNGLE BOOK,"
THEY GO, HE WAS RAISED
BY A PACK OF WOLVES?
>> UH-HUH.
>> SHE WAS RAISED BY A PACK OF
DRAG QUEENS.
>> (laughs) I WAS, LITERALLY.
>> (laughs)
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> YEAH, TAKE THAT.
>> I THINK JASLENE MADE A
MISTAKE BECAUSE
THE FOUR SIDES THAT SHE CHOSE
WEREN'T REALLY DIVERSE ENOUGH.
JASLENE'S GONNA HAVE TO GO
INTO THE JUDGING ROOM
AND SELL IT TO THE JUDGES.
LET'S DO "SEXY."
THAT LAST ONE, THE "SEXY"--
IT WAS LIKE THERE COULD'VE BEEN
DOG POO ON THE SIDEWALK,
AND YOU WERE SMELLING IT.
>> OH.
>> SO GIVE ME "SURPRISED" NOW.
>> (laughing) OH!
>> NATASHA--
I TOLD HER THAT INFORMATION
BEFORE SHE DID
HER SURPRISED SHOT,
AND THE--HER SURPRISED SHOT
WAS BRILLIANT.
>> THEY TOLD ME LAST NIGHT
THAT I'M THE OUTCAST
AND NOBODY LIKES TO HANG OUT
WITH ME,
AND I'M LIKE, WELL, GOOD.
>> DO YOU LIKE THIS BETTER?
>> YES.
>> I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S PRESSURE ON ME
THIS TIME AROUND
BECAUSE JAY MANUEL
GAVE ME SUCH HARSH COMMENTS.
>> MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOU WERE THE WORST OF THE DAY.
YOU NEED TO BE MORE CAREFREE,
REGARDLESS OF THE CHARACTER
OR THE SHOOT.
>> SO, WHITELLE, THE FIRST ONE
WE'RE GONNA START WITH
IS SEDUCTRESS.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> IT'S ALMOST LOOKING
A LITTLE--
A LITTLE LIKE BAD CATALOGUE.
>> CHIN UP.
>> WHITNEY HAS TO REMEMBER,
WHEN POSING IN A TIGHT AREA
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT BRINGING YOUR ARMS
TOO MUCH INTO THE FRAME
AND BENDING INWARD,
BECAUSE IT MAKES YOU LOOK
REALLY, REALLY ROUND
REGARDLESS OF YOUR WEIGHT.
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME
THE "COMEDIAN" NOW?
MIGHT BE TRICKY.
>> DESPITE JAY'S
NEGATIVE COMMENTS
FROM THIS WEEK,
I TRIED TO DO THE BEST I COULD.
IF I GO HOME,
THEN AT LEAST I CAN GO OUT
KNOWING THAT I DID A GOOD JOB.
>> (laughs)
>> OH, LORD,
YOU'RE VERY SPECIAL.
>> (laughs)
>> OKAY, LET'S START
OFF WITH "SEXY BEAST."
>> AAH!
>> STAY LIKE THAT. HOLD ON.
>> NOW YOU GOTTA SELL JAEL
THE REVOLUTIONARY/PEACEMAKER.
>> BECAUSE I'M A MARTYR
OF THE UNIVERSE'S HAPPINESS,
AND YOU MAY CAPTURE IT.
>> OH, LORD.
THE THING THAT
I HATED THE MOST ABOUT JAEL WAS
THIS OVERLY DRAGGED-OUT MAKEUP,
BUT HER PERFORMANCE WAS GENIUS,
REMINISCENT OF GRACE JONES.
>> I LIKE TO SHAKE IT OUT A
LITTLE BIT.
>> GOOD. MOVE AROUND.
>> 'CAUSE I POSE TOO MUCH.
I HAVE TO REALLY REMEMBER THAT
EVERY SINGLE TIME I GET ON SET
IS TO NOT POSE AT ALL.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> THESE ARE PRETTY.
THEY'RE ALL POSED.
EVERY TIME I TELL YOU
TO STOP POSING,
YOUR PICTURES BECOME GENIUS.
WELL, WE ALREADY HAVE
"ANGER" UP, SO YOU GOTTA DO IT.
>> ANGER?
OKAY, LET'S DO ANGER THEN.
>> YOU'RE POSING AGAIN.
YOU WANT ME TO MAKE YOU MAD?
WANNA GO HOME THIS WEEK?
>> NO.
>> USE THAT FRUSTRATION.
>> SARAH--I THINK SHE CAN DO
ANYTHING SHE SETS HER MIND TO.
BUT SOMETIMES YOU JUST NEED
A LITTLE BIT OF A PUSH.
LET IT GO!
>> AAH!
>> "REGRET" IS A GOOD ONE TO DO
AFTER THAT ONE.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> OKAY.
>> WEEK AFTER WEEK AFTER WEEK,
I KEEP PUSHING SARAH
TO GO PAST HER SAFETY ZONE,
TO MAKE HER POSES
LOOK MORE GENUINE,
MAKE THEM MORE REAL.
>> MY HAIR HAS BEEN POSSESSED
BY AN EVIL SPIRIT.
>> THERE GOES ONE THERE.
>> IT'S TAKEN OVER
AND DESTROYED IT.
>> PERFECT.
>> TODAY, WE FOUND
BRITTANY'S WEAK SPOT.
BRITTANY STARTED OFF STRONG,
AND I THINK BRIT
WAS A LITTLE COCKY.
BRIT'S LAST SHOT
FELL COMPLETELY FLAT.
ONE SHOT WAS YOUR WEAKEST SHOT
OUT OF THE WHOLE COMPETITION.
IT WAS JUST
VERY CONFUSED-LOOKING,
NOT... DEVILISH.
>> (whispers) SOMEBODY ALWAYS
DOES WORSE THAN US.
IT'S OKAY.
>> THE GIRLS NEED
TO BE VERY CAREFUL
WHO THEY MAKE FEEL
LIKE AN OUTCAST,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHO THEY'RE MESSING WITH.
>> SO WE'RE GONNA START OFF
WITH THE "DARK SIDE."
>> I THINK JAEL
WAS GIVING ME THE EVIL EYE,
HOPING THAT
I'D FALL FLAT ON MY FACE.
BUT I DIDN'T, AND, UH,
I JUST GAVE HER THE EVIL EYE
RIGHT BACK.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> YOU'RE GONNA GO
TO YOUR SEXUAL SIDE NOW.
RENEE'S SEXY SIDE
LOOKED THE SAME
AS THE DARK SIDE.
I WOULD MAKE IT
A LITTLE MORE "COME HITHER."
CAN YOU GIVE ME "SORROW"
WITH SOME EYE CONTACT
FOR ONE FRAME?
I THINK WITH RENEE,
SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT THE PROBLEM IS
SHE NEEDS TO LEARN
HOW TO TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
DIONNE, WHITELLE, JASLENE--
SINCE DIONNE WON THE CHALLENGE
AND SHE CHOSE THE TWO OF YOU,
YOU'RE ALL GOING NOW
TO DO YOUR KEDS ADVERTORIAL
FOR "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
>> (laughs)
>> FROM THIS SHOOT.
YOU GOTTA WHISK RIGHT OFF
TO WORK, SO NO DOWNTIME FOR YOU.
>> (cheering)
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL SEE YOU GUYS SOON.
>> LET'S GO!
♪♪
>> HI, GUYS. HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD!
>> I'M JENNIFER WEIDERMAN,
VICE PRESIDENT OF MARKETING
FOR KEDS.
WE'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO SHOOT A KEDS AD
IN THE JUNE ISSUE
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
SO LET'S GET THIS STARTED.
>> AND I AM SO THANKFUL
BENNY CHOSE ME AS THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE.
IT WAS SO FUN
BECAUSE THEY DRESS US UP.
THEY DO OUR HAIR AND OUR MAKEUP.
THEY WANT US TO BE, LIKE,
17 AGAIN.
>> KEEP SWITCHING YOUR LEGS UP.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> I HAVE NEVER
MODELED SHOES BEFORE,
AND THAT TEACH THAT WE GOT
FROM BENNY NINJA?
>> POSE. IT'S ABOUT THE SHOE.
>> ALL THAT ACTUALLY PAID OFF.
>> WE HAVE THE SHOT, GIRLS.
IT WAS GREAT.
>> YAY!
>> THANK YOU. IT'S A WRAP.
♪♪
>> YEAH!
>> HI!
>> HI, Y'ALL!
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> GOOD.
>> YOU GUYS JUST CAME FROM
A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND I JUST CAME FROM A PHOTO
SHOOT, TOO,
SO PLEASE EXCUSE
MY EXTREME MAKEUP.
>> TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
JUST SIT AROUND
AND CHITCHAT WITH TYRA.
>> WHAT I THINK I WANNA
TALK TO YOU ALL ABOUT TODAY
IS, LIKE, REVELATIONS AND WHAT
THIS COMPETITION BRINGS.
I FEEL LIKE WE MAYBE
COME INTO THIS COMPETITION
ONE WAY,
BUT AS IT STARTS GOING ON,
YOU START FIGURING THINGS OUT
ABOUT YOURSELF,
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE.
AND I WANNA TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THAT.
SO, UM, YOU WANNA START,
BRITTANY?
>> LOOK, IT'S CRAZY.
>> YEAH.
>> (crying) THE ACTUAL WEAVE IS
RIPPING THIS HAIR OUT OF MY
HEAD.
>> OH, MY GOD, AND IT'S BRIGHT
RED.
WELL, WE'LL HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING THEM
PUT THAT CHEAP WEAVE IN YOUR
HEAD.
>> (laughs)
>> I THINK YOUR REVELATION TODAY
IS SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO SPEAK
UP.
RIGHT?
ANYBODY ELSE WANNA TALK ABOUT
REVELATIONS?
YOU WANNA TALK?
>> WHEN BENNY ASKED ME
WHAT WAS THE HARDEST THING
ABOUT BEING IN THIS COMPETITION,
IT'S BEING AWAY FROM MY BABY.
IT WAS, LIKE, TEARS STARTED
COMING--
LIKE THEY ABOUT TO COME OUT NOW.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> DON'T LET 'EM OUT.
>> HOW DOES IT FEEL TO BE AWAY
FROM YOUR BABY
FOR SUCH PERIODS OF TIME?
>> IT'S HARD!
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I KNOW
I'M DOING IT FOR BOTH OF US.
>> JAEL.
>> I DON'T KNOW. I JUST--
I FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT MYSELF
BECAUSE OF ALL THE EXPERIENCES
IN MY LIFE, AND IT'S HELPED ME.
YOU KNOW, 'CAUSE I HAD
DEALT WITH THAT DEATH,
AND I'M STILL
DEALING WITH THAT DEATH.
AND SO I WAS LIKE,
OKAY, NOW WHAT DO I DO?
>> DEATH HAPPENS,
AND WHEN DEATH HAPPENS,
WE ARE NOT EXPECTED
TO BE STOIC PEOPLE.
WE'RE NOT EXPECTED
TO BE LIKE THAT...
BECAUSE THEN PEOPLE WILL
START LOOKING AT YOU LIKE,
DOES SHE HAVE A HEART?
IS SHE CRAZY?
ONE OF HER BEST
FRIENDS JUST DIED,
AND SHE'S JUST DRY-EYED
AND WANTS TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND THAT'S IT?
ANYONE ELSE?
>> I FEEL LIKE
I'M REALLY MISUNDERSTOOD.
I'M NOT TRYING TO SAY THAT
I'M NOT MEAN, I'M NOT THIS,
I'M NOT THAT.
WHEN I CAME INTO THIS
COMPETITION, TYRA,
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
I HAVE A FAMILY TO TAKE CARE OF.
>> MM-HMM.
>> MY HUSBAND WAS
LIVING ON THE BEACH.
MY SON WAS LIVING WITH HIS MOM.
I HAVE A LOT ON MY SHOULDERS
RIGHT NOW, AND I DON'T CARE
IF I MAKE FRIENDS.
THAT'S NOT MY MAIN GOAL
FOR BEING HERE,
IS NOT TO MAKE FRIENDS.
>> MM-HMM.
>> IT'S TO WIN THE COMPETITION,
TO MAKE SOMETHING
OUT OF MY LIFE.
>> HAS SHE RUBBED
ANY OF YOU GUYS THE WRONG WAY?
>> ALL OF US.
>> EVERYBODY?
>> THAT'S JUST BAD ENERGY.
>> OH.
>> BUT YOU GUYS ARE ALL TREATING
ME
LIKE I'M SUCH A BAD PERSON,
AND I'M NOT.
>> BUT, RENEE--
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
WOULD BE BEST, RENEE?
IS IF YOU SIT RIGHT HERE
NEXT TO ME, AND I THINK THE BEST
THING WHEN, LIKE, YOU'RE FEELING
ATTACKED
AND EVERYBODY'S AGAINST YOU
IS FOR EVERYBODY TO GO AND SAY
HOW YOU'VE HURT THEM.
ALL RIGHT, SO... SHOOT.
>> YOU'VE BEEN NEGATIVE
TO EVERYBODY SO MANY TIMES.
IT'S LIKE,
HOW AM I GONNA BELIEVE YOU?
>> AT THE CASTING WEEK,
YOU WERE NOT SAYING
VERY GOOD THINGS.
>> I FEEL LIKE
SHE HAS MORE ISSUES INSIDE
THAT SHE HAS TO DEAL WITH,
'CAUSE I THINK
THAT'S JUST ALL A FRONT.
>> SHE MAKES A LOT
OF VALID POINTS WHEN SHE SAYS
THAT THERE IS STUFF
GOING ON INTERNALLY WITH YOU.
>> SOMETIMES WHEN YOU TALK,
YOU HAVE A TENDENCY
TO TALK DOWN TO SOMEBODY.
>> YEAH, I FEEL LIKE
YOU WOULD SAY SOMETHING
TO SARAH OR BRITTANY
THAT YOU WOULD NEVER SAY TO ME.
>> NEVER SAY TO ME.
>> THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
TO ADDRESS ALL OF THESE GIRLS...
RIGHT NOW.
>> (sniffles)
I'M SORRY FOR ANYTHING
I MIGHT'VE SAID
TO HURT OR OFFEND YOU GUYS.
IT'S A DEFENSE MECHANISM
FOR MYSELF.
I'VE BEEN HURT BY--
ANYBODY THAT I'VE EVER LOVED,
BESIDES MY HUSBAND AND MY SON,
HAS HURT ME.
SO I'M--I'M VERY...
(sniffles)
I'M SORRY.
>> RENEE, EVERYBODY HAS A STORY
FOR THE REASON WHY
THEY ARE THAT WAY.
SO YOU WERE HURT BY PEOPLE.
HURT PEOPLE HURT.
BUT I THINK YOUR REVELATION
IS THAT--
REALIZING HOW MUCH PAIN
THAT YOU HAVE INSIDE.
AND TO COPE, YOUR FUEL IS
TO HURT OTHER PEOPLE,
AND SOMETIMES TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
IT'S HAPPENING.
AND I HOPE--
I HOPE THAT THIS COMPETITION,
WHETHER YOU WIN
OR WHETHER YOU DON'T,
THAT YOU WALK AWAY
BEING GRATEFUL THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO REALIZE.
OKAY? OKAY. GIVE ME A HUG.
>> TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW,
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SEVEN OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I OBVIOUSLY DON'T WANNA
BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
I'M NOT READY TO GO HOME AT ALL.
>> You're gonna do good.
You know you are.
>> WELL, I KNOW I'M PROBABLY
GONNA BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO THIS TIME.
>> It was one shoot, honey.
>> YEAH, GIRLS HAVE GONE HOME
FOR ONE SHOOT.
♪♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE JUDGING
ROOM.
EIGHT WILL BE SEVEN,
BUT NOT YET.
YOU KNOW OUR FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A 6-PAGE SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT...
♪ WITH... ♪
>> COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
>> YES.
ALL RIGHT,
NOW YOU KNOW YOUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE...
TWIGGY,
LIVING LEGEND AND FASHION ICON.
AND, OF COURSE, WE SEE
OUR LOVELY GUEST JUDGE HERE--
MR. BENNY MEDINA.
HE IS MY MANAGER,
AND INCLUDING MY TALK SHOW
HE'S THE EXECUTIVE PRODUCER.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF
YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST UP IS JAEL.
ALL RIGHT, JAEL,
SO YOU HAD TO COME UP WITH
A SUPERMODEL SUPER SELF NAME,
AND YOU CAME UP WITH...
>> JAEL.
>> WELL, JAEL, I LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU HAD THE CONFIDENCE
TO BELIEVE IN YOUR OWN NAME.
>> SO, JAEL,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO EMBODY
FOUR DIFFERENT SUPER SELVES.
YOU ALSO HAD TO STYLE YOURSELF.
AND HERE ARE YOUR BEST SHOTS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> YOU WERE A SEXY BEAST,
ANARCHIST,
REVOLUTIONARY
AND DOMINATOR.
>> STRAIGHT OFF THE BAT, FOR ME,
THIS IS THE BEST YOU'VE DONE.
>> YEAH, I--IT'S A GOOD CARD.
>> LET'S SEE THE
CLOSE-UP OF "DOMINATOR."
IT LOOKS LIKE DOMINATRIX.
IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S A WHIP IN YOUR HAND
BUT IT'S JUST
CROPPED OUT OF THE SHOT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING, THOUGH,
BECAUSE ALL YOUR LOOKS,
YOU'VE PICKED VERY STRONG,
TOUGH LOOKS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN A GENTLE SIDE OF
YOU.
>> I SAY WELL DONE.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'M THE ONE
THAT EDITS THIS FILM,
AND I HAD A HARD TIME
CHOOSING YOURS, JAEL.
YOU DID REALLY WELL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS RENEE.
SO, RENEE,
YOU HAD TO DO A SUPER SELF,
SUPERMODEL NAME,
AND YOU CHOSE...
>> NAYIEN.
>> WELL, THERE CERTAINLY IS
A NAIMA...
>> OH, THERE IS A NAIMA.
>> WHO IS AN AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL.
>> I LIKE NENE, TOO.
>> NENE, I LIKE.
>> YEAH, I LIKED NENE.
>> YEAH, I SUGGEST NENE.
>> OKAY.
>> I THINK THAT WOULD BE
REALLY GOOD FOR YOU.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOTS.
>> OKAY.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> AND YOU WERE SEXUAL,
DARK SIDE,
MOTHERLY
AND SORROW.
>> PUSH IT, RENEE,
BECAUSE YOU REALLY NEED TO TAKE
IT THERE.
YOU'RE SO PRETTY,
YOU CAN AFFORD
TO GET A LITTLE UGLY.
>> LET'S SEE THE CLOSE-UP
OF "SORROW."
>> EITHER SHE'S GOT
AN INCREDIBLE SENSE OF RESTRAINT
OR YOU DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH.
THOSE EYES HAVE A LOT TO SAY...
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU DO WELL BY THEM.
>> ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS NATASHA.
SO YOUR SUPER SELF NAME IS...
>> NATA.
ALL RIGHT,
AND LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOTS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> AND YOU WERE HAPPY,
SURPRISED,
SAD...
AND SEXY.
>> REALLY GOOD PERFORMANCES.
THE--THE FIRST ONE LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE, LIKE,
SELLING A FANTASTIC VACATION.
THE SECOND ONE--
I WISHED I WAS THERE WITH YOU.
>> LET'S SEE A CLOSE-UP
OF "SEXY."
>> STRAIGHT OFF THE BAT,
I LIKE JUST THE LOOK OF IT.
WELL, IT'S GREAT. YOU
SHOCKED THE HELL OUT OF ME
WHEN I WAS EDITING YOUR FILM.
I WAS LIKE, OH, MY GOSH,
THE MODEL HAS FINALLY EMERGED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NATA.
OKAY, UP NEXT IS BRITTANY.
ALL RIGHT, BRITTANY,
SO YOU CAME UP WITH A NAME,
AND THAT NAME IS...
>> BRIT.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO, BRIT,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOTS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> AND YOU WERE INNOCENT,
SPACEY,
SECRET EVIL
AND GOOFY.
>> VERY KIND OF
PARISIAN "ELLE" MAGAZINE.
>> LET'S SEE THE CLOSE-UP
OF "INNOCENT."
VERY "I LOVE LUCY."
>> IT'S REALLY SWEET. I LOVE IT.
>> THANK YOU, BRIT.
ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IT WHITNEY.
SO, WHITNEY,
YOU HAD TO COME UP WITH
A SUPERMODEL SUPER SELF NAME
TO MAKE PEOPLE REMEMBER YOU,
AND THAT IS...
>> WHITELLE.
>> OH, MY.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S SORT OF
LIKE A DEPARTMENT STORE.
"WE'RE GOING TO WHITELLE'S."
>> WHERE'D YOU BUY THAT--
WHERE'D YOU BUY THAT SHIRT,
NIGEL? IT'S CUTE.
>> IT'S GREAT. IT'S FROM
WHITELLE'S.
(laughing)
>> AND YOU WERE SECRETIVE,
PEACEFUL,
THINKER
AND COMEDIAN.
OKAY, LET'S SEE
YOUR "PEACEFUL" SHOT.
>> I GUESS ALSO, WHITNEY,
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
IS IT ENDS UP LOOKING
ALMOST A LITTLE AMATEUR.
BUT THIS, FOR ME... IT'S ALL--
IT'S JUST AMATEUR DRAMATICS.
>> IT'S SOMETHING YOU NEED
TO LEARN TO CONTROL, THOUGH,
BECAUSE YOU DO THAT
IN A LOT OF YOUR PICTURES,
AND IT LOOKS HARSH.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT...
JASLENE.
ALL RIGHT, JASLENE,
SO YOU HAD TO DO
A SUPERMODEL SUPER SELF NAME,
AND THAT NAME IS...
>> JASLENE.
>> WELL, I'M GLAD YOU KEPT YOUR
NAME,
AND I'M GLAD JAEL KEPT HER NAME,
'CAUSE I THOUGHT THOSE WERE THE
TWO NAMES
THAT WERE VERY ORIGINAL.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE YOUR BEST
SHOTS.
AND YOU WERE SENTIMENTAL,
DRAG QUEEN,
CHA CHA DIVA
AND MODELESQUE.
>> THEY ALL LOOK BEAUTIFUL,
BUT THEY ACTUALLY ALL LOOK THE
SAME.
>> LET'S SEE YOUR CLOSE-UP OF
"SENTIMENTAL."
>> I MEAN, IT'S A VERY PRETTY
PICTURE,
BUT IT DOESN'T LOOK SENTIMENTAL,
DOES IT?
>> MNH-MNH.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE
JANICE DICKINSON,
THE MORE I LOOK AT YOU, GIRL.
YOU LOOK JUST LIKE HER.
IT'S INSANE.
>> SHE DOES.
>> A LOT OF YOUR MODELING IS
GONNA BE ON A WHITE BACKGROUND,
BUT THAT PHOTOGRAPHER
OR THAT ART DIRECTOR IS
GONNA WANT A CERTAIN EMOTION,
AND IF YOU JUST BRING THIS,
THEY'RE GONNA BE LIKE, WHAT'S--
WHAT DID I HIRE HER FOR?
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, JASLENE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SARAH.
SO, SARAH, YOU HAD A NAME
TO COME UP WITH,
AND YOUR NAME WAS...
>> MOE.
>> IT'S FUNNY.
EVERY TIME YOU DO "MOE,"
DO YOU REALIZE YOU DO SOMETHING
LIKE, "MOE"?
LIKE, REALLY GOOFY.
>> ALL RIGHT, MOE,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOTS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> AND YOU WERE INNOCENT,
ANGRY,
SAD
AND HAPPY.
>> AND THEY DO LOOK POSED.
THEY DON'T LOOK NATURAL.
ALMOST--I DON'T THINK
ANY OF THEM LOOK NATURAL TO ME.
I THINK YOU DON'T LET YOUR GUARD
DOWN IS YOUR PROBLEM.
>> ALL RIGHT, SARAH,
LET'S SEE YOUR CLOSE-UP
OF "HAPPY."
>> THIS IS CORNY.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS
TOO ON THE HEAD AND TOO CORNY
AND NOT EXOTIC
OR INTERESTING AT ALL.
>> I WAS JUST LIKE,WHAT IS THIS?
THE HAIR JUST LOOKED KIND OF
COMMERCIAL, BUT I SEE
TECHNICAL GOOD MODELING.
>> THERE'S NO WAY THAT'S REAL.
>> ALL RIGHT, SARAH, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS DIONNE.
SO, DIONNE,
YOU HAD A SUPER SELF NAME,
AND THAT NAME IS...
>> WHOLAHAY.
>> WHOLA-WHO?
>> (laughs)
>> IT'S NOT A GREAT NAME.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOUR--YOUR SKIN COLOR
IS SO PRETTY.
WHAT ABOUT "BROWN"?
I--DO YOU LIKE BROWN?
>> I LIKE BROWN.
>> AND DON'T GO ADDING
NO "WHOLAHAY BROWN."
(laughter)
(camera shutter snaps)
>> AND YOU WERE FRIENDLY,
EVIL,
'HOOD
AND SENSITIVE.
LET'S CHECK OUT "'HOOD."
>> IT LOOKS MORE LIKE
A KIND OF PEEVED OFF HOUSEWIFE.
>> GIRL FROM THE 'HOOD AND
PISSED OFF HOUSEWIFE
IS THE SAME THING.
>> (laughs)
>> UH, MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOU ALWAYS DO A GOOD JOB,
WHICH IS YOUR DOWNFALL.
YOU NEED TO TAKE IT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, YOU'RE WELCOME.
IT IS TIME FOR US JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE, AND AFTER THAT,
I WILL CALL YOU BACK,
AND I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF
YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
>> OKAY, SO NOW
IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE GIRLS
IS GOING HOME.
NATA...
(camera shutter snaps)
>> BETTER KNOWN AS NATASHA.
>> I LOVE HER.
SHE HIT THE NAIL
ON ALL FOUR PHOTOS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE'S MADE WRONG THE NEW RIGHT.
>> I'M HAPPY WE KEPT HER AROUND
BECAUSE SHE'S SHOWING US
THAT IT'S IN THERE.
>> YEAH.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> JAEL.
>> THESE PHOTOGRAPHS ARE GREAT.
SHE'S A BIT TOUGH-LOOKING FOR
ME.
I HAVEN'T SEEN A SOFTER SIDE.
>> AND THESE ARE THE BEST SHOTS
I'VE EVER SEEN OF JAEL.
I THINK JAEL'S GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> RENEE, A.K.A. NENE.
>> I'M NOT TERRIBLY MOVED.
I FOUND THAT SHE HAD SORT OF
THIS
KIND OF DIRTY SOPHISTICATION.
>> THIS WAS HER CHANCE
TO GIVE ALL THE EMOTIONS
THAT WE TELL HER
TO KEEP PULLING UP,
AND SHE TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY
TO... (makes whooshing sound)
(camera shutter snaps)
>> BRITTANY, ALSO KNOWN AS BRIT.
>> MY HEART GOES OUT TO HER
ABOUT HER HAIR.
>> WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
>> I THINK BRIT IS INNOCENT.
I THINK SHE'S SPACEY.
I THINK SHE'S SECRET EVIL,
AND I THINK SHE'S GOOFY.
>> (laughs)
(camera shutter snaps)
>> WHITELLE... WHITNEY.
>> I JUST DON'T GET
THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS.
SORRY.
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS
AS--AS A PRETTY LADY.
>> I FEEL LIKE
WHITNEY HAS THIS PACKAGE.
SHE SPEAKS SO WELL.
SHE EXPRESSES HERSELF SO WELL.
>> THAT AIN'T WHAT THE GIG CALLS
FOR.
FOR THE MOST PART, THERE ARE
OTHER STANDARDS
THAT WE, UH, LOOK TO
FOR A MODEL,
AND I DON'T THINK SHE HAS THEM.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> JASLENE.
>> OH, JASLENE DID NOT
LEAN ON ME TODAY.
SHE JUST FELL.
>> YES.
>> SHE JUST FELL FLAT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> SARAH/MOE.
>> SHE CAPTURED SOME THINGS,
AND THEY DO LOOK STYLIZED.
THEY DO LOOK STAGED.
>> SHE'S A POSER.
>> AND SHE'S TAKEN SOME OKAY
PICTURES,
BUT I DON'T THINK THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE COMPETITION
SHE'S TAKEN THE BEST PICTURES.
>> I THINK SHE JUST PROBABLY
TAKES THE BEST THAT SHE CAN.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> BROWN, A.K.A. DIONNE.
>> I LOVED THE CHOICE FOR HER
HAIRSTYLE.
>> I REALLY LIKE THIS GIRL.
REALLY ELOQUENT, REALLY SEXY.
THERE'S A SPIRIT IN HER.
I-I THINK THIS GIRL
WILL HAVE A GREAT CAREER.
>> WHOLAHAY.
>> (laughs)
>> (speaking faux African
dialect)
WHOLAHAY?
(clicking tongue)
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> EIGHT OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SEVEN OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
JAEL.
>> (sighs)
>> FIRST TIME
BEING CALLED FIRST?
>> YES.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ROCKED THESE PHOTOS.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
NATASHA/NATA.
SOMEBODY'S
PROVING TO BE A MODEL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU SO MUCH,
TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
DIONNE--BROWN.
>> OOH! (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS, BROWN.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> BRITTANY/BRIT.
THIS WAS VERY GOOD.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT HAMSTER
THAT HAS DIED ON YOUR HEAD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (laughs)
>> RENEE/NENE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, RENEE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JASLENE.
>> WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT YOU CAN SHINE
ON A WHITE BACKDROP
WITH SOME DIRECTION,
AND NOT WITH A CIRCUS
ALL AROUND YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL WHITNEY AND SARAH
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BAGS, GO HOME.
BOTH OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
SARAH, THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE
YOUR PICTURES ARE POSED--
MODELING 101.
BUT THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THERE'S ANYTHING EXTRA,
AND THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN THE REAL YOU.
WHITNEY, THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE
THEY'VE GIVEN YOU CHANCES.
AND WE FEEL LIKE,
WEEK AFTER WEEK,
YOUR PHOTOS ARE PRETTY
BUT NOT A MODEL.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
ONE MORE CHANCE, WHITNEY.
>> OH, MY LORD.
>> OH!
>> (sniffles)
>> (exhales deeply)
>> THIS WEEK, YOU GOT TO TAKING
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
BUT YOU HAVE TO PROVE
THAT IT'S A MODEL, TOO,
AND MODELS NOT--
AREN'T JUST PRETTY.
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE.
>> MM-HMM.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU, SARAH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> COME HERE.
I THINK YOU JUST NEED TO RELAX
AND JUST TRUST YOUR BEAUTY,
THAT YOU'RE JUST GREAT
JUST WHO YOU ARE.
OKAY?
>> THANK YOU. (sniffles)
>> HEY.
>> I KNOW.
>> SARAH.
>> BYE, BABIES.
>> BYE.
>> BYE-BYE.
♪♪
>> I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED.
I WANTED THIS SO BADLY.
I REALLY DID WANT THIS
MORE THAN ANYTHING.
I OPENED UP MORE THAN
I'VE EVER OPENED UP,
AND I THOUGHT
THAT WOULD REALLY SHOW THEM
THAT I'M TRYING SO HARD.
BUT AT LEAST
I CAME OUT OF THIS COMPETITION
KNOWING THAT
IT'S OKAY TO BE MYSELF,
AND IT'S OKAY, YOU KNOW?
♪♪
>> COMING UP ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL"...
>> WHAT THE HELL?!
>> THERE'S BIG SURPRISES
AT THE TOP MODEL HOUSE,
BUT MOTHERHOOD AND MODELING
AREN'T MIXING FOR NATASHA.
>> I CANNOT PRETEND LIKE
I DON'T FEEL ANYTHING.
>> (screams)
>> AND THE GIRLS GET
A BLAST FROM THE PAST
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
>> IT'S A WHOLE
"TOP MODEL" REUNION.
>> (screaming and laughing)